Cause I remember Rebecca and your kids were on state. Like went on,
you know, when, if celebrating and I remember feeling, I don't really, like,
I don't have a photographic memory,
but the sense that I got was I remember going, Oh, he's got a great family.
I really honestly the joy.
In the, your kids, you know, face and just the joy that we felt watching.
It was just the, uh, memorable.
Let's back up a second.
You have a very clear recollection of that fight night.
I know. I don't have video.
We have video footage of you reacting to this thing, winning.
I need this, I need this. I will look for it, but you keep, keep going. Yeah.
Okay. Sit down, Bobby, relax. This is going to be really awkward.
Of course, fields in between you and me. Don't worry. I'm retired.
Sit down. This is going to get really awkward for you. Okay. So we had,
we had our entire family over and your brother and I,
you were acting like the Oracle.
You said there was not a chance in hell that he could ever.
Or anyone, this wire won't give him a picture of the company.
Remember this? And then your brother and I, and Gilbert, we said, I wouldn't,
I wouldn't speak so fast. We had you man, the whole night we had you. We had,
and then he knocks him out and you
ran to three different bedrooms.
Came back with your tail between your legs and you were in total disbelief.
Do you remember that? You said there was not a chance in.
I thought we were right there, bud.
I don't recall the words. I don't recall it like we're brothers now
I'll say the video. We'll post this right here we go. Oh, here we go.
Wait, hold on. Rewind it, rewind it. Remind it, rewind it.
It's just going to embarrass me. I had a thousand,
a thousand dollars in Luke. Rockhold
[inaudible]. Wow. Gilbert and I hope you're excited.
Well, thank you very much, everybody. That's showing excitement. I apologize.
The one person is disappointed.
[inaudible] be honest. Be honest, be honest.
You guys recreated this recently.
You knew it was COVID you thought let's play a thousand, 16 and 14. Well,
that's great. Thank you. Well with this guy, of course,
I got a suspicious bind. Cause he's from San Diego. Here's here's the thing,
right?
That's regroup. Yeah. Okay. We watch every fight.
We've watched every one of your fights. Okay. That's that's number one.
Have a hard one for a long time. Okay. I know, but we did. Right.
And I have to be honest with you. Okay. That was very real. I'll tell you why,
because Luke Rockhold is from Santa Cruz or whatever. Right.
And he skateboards I'm from San Diego. Right? So I feel like.
He's like your skateboard I used to, right? No,
I was going to say so he's from Santa Cruz. You're from San Diego. No.
Where near each other.
[inaudible] you guys are boys and you could
[inaudible] that's true on the podcast. How many times this, Michael,
let me ask you this. How many times does Luke face? Rochel done my podcast.
None ask him. All right. All right. So that's number two.
True number. And also I'm sweating. Here's the second thing. Okay. Is this that?
Sure. 2016, right? Right.
It was the night where I laid down in bed and I became a Michael Bisbing fan.
All right. Yes. Yes. All right. I watched your season of the ultimate Sam.
I didn't even know what that was. Okay. You were a little behind.
I was a little behind. So what I'm saying is, is that okay? Yeah. At the time.
That's a real man. That's a real up. Shut the up everybody. All right.
At the time. Right.
I was rooting for Luke Rockhold and at the time when you open your eyes,
I am opening my eyes. I mean, you face.
Right? Yeah. This is why it is the go. Right.
Right. And, um, and at the time I was rooting for him. And when he,
you knocked him out, it was such a shock to my system.
But then I was reborn like a Phoenix. Wow. And I, and I,
and I wasn't convinced from that day forward, right.
That you were the guy. Okay.
When you hear that.
I wanted him to win.
I want my glee. No. Well, come on, everybody likes George. Let's be honest.
He's a sweetheart.
See, here's the thing. When I met Khalilah,
I had stopped watching UFC for a long time.
A long time. I couldn't even, I couldn't. Yeah. And so.
The George St. Pierre years,
I was in Houston when he lost a max Serra, Matt Serra.
Cause I was the Jordan Peele, you know who directed get out. Yes.
So the UFC for one night hired me and Jordan Peele to do some sort of
comedy thing at some red carpet event for them. Right.
And they never asked us again,
but it was me and Jordan were in Houston when we saw George St. Pierre,
Lucy met Sarah. And I remember everyone was shocked and I was so like,
not involved that I didn't even know that that was a big deal. Right.
It's when I met her on Tinder.
Testing, do you always have.
And she was a big fan. I slowly got back into the UFC. Right.
So for me, you know, I wasn't a George Sr.
Okay. Okay. Hold on. Let me, let me just stop you right there.
I'm going to give you some advice. Probably. I don't need advice. Well, I'm,
I'm going to give you some and you're going to hear this. You're going to go.
Oh, interesting. Yeah. I'll take that on board next time. You're with a fighter.
Right. And you know,
you're clearly making my fighting ability, the,
the conversation piece. And you talk about a former opponent of mine.
Don't intro the conversation about the opponent who beat me by saying,
Oh yeah. I remember watching him get his kicked one time.
And then he went on to beat
[inaudible] you're right. You're wrong. I mean, just say, wow.
The greatest of all time, Joe tip yet he was unstoppable.
That would have been better. I remember when he got his asking
[inaudible] I always saw that as a fluke. Wasn't it like? Oh, no. He caught him.
Okay. So I want to say this. Okay. Kind of fluky,
but I did not go to journalism school. Okay. All right.
I've never went to college. Okay. I'm just telling you that.
I'm just like this little weird Korean fella. You know what I mean? In 1995,
I walked by a comedy club and I signed up for an amateur night. I have no,
is that true? Yeah. I have no skills whatsoever. And I went up,
I don't know anything. Right. So, um,
in terms of talking to people and being a journalist or interviewer,
I don't know what I'm doing. You don't need to be. I know my point, my point is,
is that, you know, um, I think that, um, you know, I apologize.
It's okay. I don't, I don't, I want to make you a better person.
I know. I want to do it. I'm trying to, I want to learn. Okay. I it up.
Right. Because I up. Right. I up the Luke Rockhold thing. Right.
And I up the George St. Pierre thing. Right. And I'm learning as I go. Okay.
And I apologize. Okay. I apology this salt necessary. Okay.
Let's talk about fully accepted. Let's talk about Saturday again. Okay.
So do you think that.